hi guys Greg Alva here John here
Humphrey Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Man's Chest is coming out this week and
we got our tickets for it already we're
going up super late night showing that
meant
hell no damn it tell no tales my bad den
mad chess is the second one
so with this week John and I re watching
he hasn't seen three and four I haven't
I've seen all four and we're we're
watching all the movies this week and
we're going to be doing reviews and each
one you know do balloon filled reviews
should review that's it we're doing we
what we wanted to do for aliens but then
we saw alien early so we really liked
the one time we got to see a huge movie
like two weeks in advance so we're doing
our juicer review series or kicking off
a Pirates of the Caribbean the curse of
the Black Pearl back pub and this is an
interesting experience because you saw
this in the theaters and was something
we were like as well 13 12 or 13
somewhere there you're probably 13 and I
was like 12 and I saw a boy with my
family we had to the cinema and I was
dazzled and it was a magical experience
that first movie is one of the rare
movie theatre experiences where I
remember watch like when watching seams
again when we watch the last night I
remember watching those certain scenes
in two theaters and how I felt when I
watched it and how magical it was just a
little touches like it's scary and
suspenseful in the beginning and then
when it you know they show Orlando Bloom
when he's like it takes the candle off
the wall and everyone's laughing and the
tone starts to slowly shift and you see
Jack's mayor over the first time and
it's hilarious a ship sinking um yeah I
really remember I share that with you
because thinking back on this movie I do
remember the room like the theater like
I remember the whole yeah I remember the
higher feelings that I was generating
and it's one it was hands-down easily
one of the best movie theater
experiences I've ever had re watching
this film I've seen it probably like 20
times at this point I've seen it so many
times and on the twenty first viewing
you notice what's now refers to and it's
sort of funny realizing some things that
I've heard before and I'm relaunching it
finally there's been a few years since
I've seen it it does kind of drag a
little bit you get like two-thirds of
the way yeah it's apt because it's a
hell you guys have seen the movie
already but at this point so we don't
need to like break down the plot for you
guys but it's a right around of time I
think when they commandeer the the ship
and one day when they trick the Navy
fleet into taking it into taking the
wrong ship and then they escape on that
one ship Jack Sparrow and rely Will
Turner and right around then it was such
a slow down a little bit for me but it's
still like kind of the middle ground of
some scenes are still great at some
things or not and knowing what I have in
store for the next for the few than
other pirates movies I would say this is
definitely the most solid entry this is
definitely the best entry of them all
the best Jack Sparrow performance we've
got it because watching generally
displaying a carrot yeah it's it I know
it's it's just the right amount of
animated back with enough subtlety to to
make this film work I would say the same
thing for Geoffrey Rush it was coming
because everyone's kind of outshine
every X Farrell outshines everyone in
this film but Geoffrey Rush this is the
first time I've seen this movie going
man yeah I for some reason I just never
noticed how grain-rich every Russia is
in this movie he's a perfect villain but
he too has that right layer of
heightened personality backed with that
knowing just the right level to make to
make this not to not go into this is not
a believable performance this is oh this
is over-the-top you don't feel that when
you watch Geoffrey Rush well he's like
it's appropriate when he's having fun
but there are things that really matter
to that gear after you could feel it
like there are moments there they're
kind of hard lacking for Barbosa I feel
like that's what I got away the most
with when watching this movie was the
subtle touches of Barbosa of really
feeling his motivation more than just I
want my soul back you can feel a guy who
has been robbed of his soul who can't
who have no senses anymore you feel the
you can
Acey can't touch he can't do anything in
like there's this whole reoccurring
thing about him just going to eat a
[ __ ] Apple oh yeah yeah yeah I
remember this movie pretty well and any
of your watching it that way
watching it again last night I
remembered it pretty well but it's been
a long time since I've actually seen it
I have not seen it as many times as you
have so that was one of my favorite
things going back and revisiting is like
the first time I thought I didn't
register what that that dining room
scene between Barbosa and Keira
Knightley thank you Knightley was all
it's worth yeah it was all about and I
watched this sounds like oh wow like
you're just living through her you're
literally soaking up the last scraps
that she's eating and drinking you feel
like it looks kind of creepy and
perverted but then you realize he just
envies her you know you just envies her
eating yeah yeah yeah and like that
those this the first movie especially
and then you know we're revisiting them
all but that's what I appreciate the
most going back and this movie is full
of little notes across the board like an
EJ character has their little notes the
visuals how they will denote every shot
has a little cherry inside of the main
Stroh this is not a Gore Verbinski is
perfectly composed films I think III
like gore Verbinski's work and I've
always thought he shoot this even if I
don't love his films I think he shoots
them really well no cure for whoop here
for well this baby here for wellness I
was actually watching this and I started
flashing back to the end of that movie
it's really creepy and I was like yeah
people probably around is this what Gore
Verbinski has a total knack for horror
and I think that this film has just the
right that has all the right elements of
horror where it doesn't cross too far
into Bri territory doesn't cross too far
into this is too scary for children you
brought up because this isn't as you
guys have noticed this isn't one of our
like typical review format that we do
we're kind of like this is a revisiting
review yeah that's true
yeah a revisit review and looking at you
know all the stuff for the skeletons and
everything you brought up the army of
Darkness yeah and yeah and you can
definitely learn inspiration for that
kind of whimsical yet scary flair and
that was happening with skeleton
characters and I never picked that up
the first time but there's stuff that
watching laugh I I swear like when all
the skeleton arms are pulled on through
the window the governor's window was
there like attacking the shipping like
that is straight up and the thing with
the desk drawer was get handling that's
all yeah yeah because we're cops back
important to wound school and kind of
scary yeah and what I loved going back
and re watching this was that I could
see you were talking about Gore
Verbinski as the director and I was like
yeah I think this is this may be kind of
a masterpiece for him because it has
everything I've come to associate with
his vision you know inside of it right
down to like when he did Rango like that
like this I didn't think about it like
oh wow Gore Verbinski is doing like an
animated feature but after watching
themselves like there's some great
cartoon timing it's got a cartoon energy
some comic strips up in this movie that
lends itself perfectly yeah but in this
movie is wonderfully edited - yeah this
is wonderful like the transitions that
they have always worked it's even like
little touches like at the beginning
with young Elizabeth Swann when she sees
the Black Pearl
she closes her eyes in a wakes up and
it's clear nightly like a transition
there and one of my favorite edited
moments is when Jack Sparrow of early in
the movie when he's in his cell and then
pirates from the Black Pearl like notice
oh it's Jackie's alive and then he says
something to him that like pokes one of
the pirates and he reaches his Armin
yeah Robin and it's that reveal shot
first reveal or whoa yeah it's a cool
ass shot because they've done nothing to
hint at what the curse is and this is
our first in and the way that it's
edited is like it's just a really cool
moment I think you might surprise the
trailer to reveal that but in terms of
movie watching experience it's a really
cool mode that makes you go what the
hell yeah I know and I definitely I mean
like that that was a surprise to find so
many so many moments still pack that
punch you know going back in there I
really do think you know Pirates came
out
we were I feel like we were starting to
get the really big studio machine that
we have now work point franchise is the
saying when you have you see bullets get
big and going back to revisit this you
know I saw the second movie and I liked
the second movie but I even at the time
I understood some of the complaints and
this I think into classic like a
physical eyes are pretty classic like
everything even if it does bloat out
sometimes like everything seems really
thought out and everything seems really
oh yeah this one big piece I wouldn't
say I would I don't know if I go so far
say it's one of the greatest movies of
all time but if any class I would say is
the classic and one of the best
blockbusters of all time I would say I
would definitely put it over there
because watching it back it feels like a
real movie attic the production values
are amazing the costumes are beautiful
and like there is such a CG that doesn't
always hold up but there's so much like
that you can tell they really made this
film and it's impressive it's exciting
it's adventurous I mean and even looking
back at the smaller perform the
performances that weren't as beloved
like the characters are really loved for
fans of the franchise but looking back
like Keira Knightley and Orlando Bloom
both do a really good job in the film -
yeah I appreciated them even more like I
just thought they were pretty growing up
but yeah I mean exactly
I liked the both of them innocent
pathetic chemistry I liked their choices
and I even loved you know for I found
myself really appreciating with the
whole relationship between Elizabeth and
the governor the guy Jonathan price yes
like there is everyone in this movie
even like you said even there Commodore
- he's on point like everyone's on point
everyone is playing a care even like the
the weeny second - the Commodore guy
yeah who's just kind of had that smirk
on his face the whole time like he's
even in care and all the characters have
a growth - yeah will Turner embraces the
bloodline of one of my party embraces
Mina this really kind of does glorify
piracy an honor really does
it really break it down is the ending to
me it was the first time I've seen the
ending where I'm like this doesn't make
any sense what should happen I'll give
you that when when or lad no when will
Turner for helps Jack Sparrow escape it
wasn't it so on steps in and I'm like
I'm signing with Will Turner and then
the Commodores like alright I guess
we'll let this [ __ ] go you know it's
like I get his gross up alright he's
letting Elizabeth Swann go and he's
learning to kind of find some ground of
respect for Jack Sparrow and what he and
what the Pirates have helped out with in
terms of this mission and whatnot look
fine you did home girls solid but it was
such a short conversation that has made
the Commodore and all the soldiers go
alright so what I love your soul edge
we're all about the hanging we have the
big ceremony of hanging Jack Sparrow but
let him go we won't go after him this
isn't going to be a weird PR situation
to deal with with that rest of the city
anything like and well I will Turner you
know he just helped a criminal escape up
this head we're just going to make
everyone in the Navy look really bad now
I will give you it just sort of read
like yes just what you guys do so uncool
I did we'll take to the sea its ranking
out whatever but even the little touches
I noticed more of Elizabeth swans
obsession with the Pirates from being a
little girl it's not thrown in your face
but it always comes at the right moment
like I've really bought that moment
where she where she gets discovered in
the closet with a medallion by the two
pirates the two funny henchmen which I
which I kind of appreciate because when
you first see these guys it's you the
guy with the glass eye
the shorter heavier ones if you know
that added weight that one
Kim when they first see them they like
they're killing human beings in the
beginning there's an introduction yeah
he shoots the guy in the head it was a
bits one place but as the Billy Joe if
you wish you and Julie like they're just
terrible people when you first meet them
but they become like Ola baby and there
than the rest of the films and he'll
keep going well and and I like to I
noticed this time for there's a pair on
both sides because you got the two you
got the two like Royal Guard dudes and
you got the two pirate dude you have
like tears all throughout yet it is is
that it might have been the first time
watches where I noticed how solid the
screenplay was I've always noticed
performances and direction and
excitement but what watching how
perfectly composed this script was was
what really stood out to me I going back
to my point when Elizabeth song gets
caught in the closet with the medallion
she called parlay on it and then she
starts giving a whole breakdown and even
as the film keeps going and she starts
on like learning more and understanding
the Pirates more it makes sense we could
and why she would even fall for Will
Turner when she has that moment at the
very end when she's like she's not a
he's not a blacksmith he's a pirate yeah
you know because she's always been
attracted to the pirate she's only not
even bow drawn he's not a she's our
modern-day girls not happy about that
royal wave is not about the royalty you
know well that was that was the thing
that I appreciated a lot more I
appreciate her character a lot more
because but you know before I wasn't
paying as close attention you know I was
a kid I was just like oh yeah there's
got to be a female romantically its cat
but like watching this I was like oh
it's surprisingly natural how they build
that or at least to me it was how they
built that character of how they made
her believably like a tough spongy girl
you know who just had the pig say she
does a great job - yeah yeah yeah
totally
she doesn't shoot as a wonderful job in
Orlando and Orlando Bloom I believe his
whole arc into trusting the piper
because I mean what watching like Jack
Sparrow constantly kind of manipulate
the situation I love it because he is it
is constantly going back and forth doing
he sucks at what he does and he's
amazing it would even possibly its
whatcha waiting and he has the worst of
luck with sometimes he prevailed yeah
and he has this weird quintessence of
piracy yeah
that only seems to make sense or work
for him and all these movies I still
never remember the one character's name
he's
using the phrase on all of the movies
the guy's the muttonchops yeah the my
ketchup Gibbs Gibbs yeah gives us great
of the role - yeah and I love his
loyalty and even they have an arc of
their always sticking to the pirate code
and they just leave Jack and behind the
beginning like when you in the cave and
with fighting with Barbosa but in the
end they come to rescue me and that's
another fun element of this movie that I
didn't pick up the first time - is like
everybody the whole bit like just a
running theme of the movie is eventually
people going bloody pirates you have
even the pirates say that about
observing Iraq and it just makes this
running gag out of like they do whatever
they want like even if there's a gap
code yeah and also the sword fight still
hold up they do that sort of I would or
like with Orlando Bloom and Johnny Depp
it's a really good sword fight yeah
that's like I would say they watch this
I was like this is what studio movies
are supposed to be like I'm like this is
fun and swashbuckling but it's also
engrossing and fantastical and like that
whole fight isn't just cool like at
first is at first it's very close
quarters they're going back that
technique and then it gets fun and
whimsical when they're like up on the on
the rafters and CIO I feel like the
first one had the right blend of you
know a period piece pirate movie and
mystical elements totally and and it's
the right amount of like spooky yeah
exactly but as the films keep going
saying it darker more spooking a lot
more heavy on mystical stuff which takes
away a little bit more from the realism
world but I feel like this film is the
most perfectly composed one out of all
the Pirates movies that have come out
yet yeah I was really in thrall of going
through this 14 years ago when this
regime happy yeah it was a really well
it holds up really well for a little
more than a decade ago
I kind of liked things more now than I
did before yeah and it's still really
funny yeah they're so like crappy I'm
Larry nobody seems they're still really
funny like there's some great character
cut because everyone is such a character
that there are some great character
comedy in here yeah that's probably one
of the most magical things like when you
see it done right you're like see you
can be spooky you can you can be
heartfelt you can be dark and you
make me laugh all you know why is the
wrong go
yeah and I was like well even though it
seems like that feel joke you're like
wow these are still based on the
character like I still get one at all
saying these things we have just a nice
like as a writer the nice thing when you
can see a movie yeah even like to
comment finally and then they made me do
chief yeah that was such a great like
that moment busted me not I think
murders at any other time because like
this movie one thing I got to give huge
respect to this movie for is juggling
yeah yeah because this movie has to
balance so many moving parts and most of
the time they're all kind of going in
the same direction for multiple angles
and so like that that moment one jack is
like in the middle of a completely
different yeah sequence and then just
come to that one line and it's perfect
cuz there's you know right about that
juggling because it's easy for a film
like this to get overloaded bombarded
when you've got so many characters a
bunch of different plot lines that are
all connecting to the same thing and yet
I never once thought it was overload I'm
not once that I actually think too much
or or did I forget about a plot or be
like more lumens yeah while they might
have to tie it all up like the movie
ends yeah as yeah
it ends in a wayward you can see sequels
but you don't eat equals yeah quite as
opposed to two and three news is that
one ends in a way where yeah this is a
perfect part one and at the same time
you know like the pirates movies have
been talked about as being you know just
money-making machines that's why they
you make them but they have things in
them where you're like do they have
these sequels in mind prior they talked
about Davy Jones a couple times but
that's that's a that's a well-worn
see thing like that that ages old oh no
I know but they still mentioned the Davy
Jones the but they put anything pirate
we're not let me finish my list job they
take like the dead men tell no tales
they have they have bootstrap bill who
becomes a prominent character in two and
three that's that's my there there's a
but they all but they all make these
things that they're mentioning a
prevalent part of all the sequels I
think I think it's half coincidence I
think they probably just got the idea to
go oh we could actually make a real Davy
Jones now that we're going to do this
again you know or I think the one thing
they definitely probably thought about
what would have been bootstrap build a
trap bill yeah because I don't think
there's anything real underneath all
that the other thing to some music
no the meantime is always been great
yeah and I just forgot how much of of a
score there is there cuz I'm you know
you always think of it done done using a
main theme so there are a lot of great
things in like that that wouldn't like
flute pipe sing and it shows up
throughout the score is great like and
that's something I don't remember as
well from at least the second movie is
like the score has a distinct aura that
really makes you feel like you're out
there yeah some somehow you know it's
not just swash buckling it's also really
kind of you know it has a dark and
magical totally I go well yeah I mean I
would say this film is fantastic I would
say borderline masterpiece yeah yeah in
terms of like a studio like a
blockbuster masterpiece yeah yeah this
is like an ideal blockbuster for me like
there are only a couple complaints I can
think of and and everything else was
just kind of a tree you know yeah
because they've always written the
movies two hours of 20 minutes because
the action sequences go on for like this
the action sequences go on for a while
yeah I don't Majan the scripts have like
ten pages of action sequence do you know
we're in and out but in terms of like a
story it's all perfectly there the
action scenes go on for a while now and
they're all perfectly composed as humors
they're it's magical and it's to this
day is it's still a magical experience
totally so yeah and I'm sure that even
though this review is this retro review
is primarily praised there will be a
later movie for that I know we're coming
yeah oh joy it wallet laughing enjoy
telling us that we love everything
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the real rejects dat John Humphrey on
Instagram and Twitter go check out our
patreon where we got a bunch of
exclusive rewards for you guys bunch of
exclusive video content to you at our
lowest reward tiers to go check it out
soon as you can
much love to everyone who watched this
video and what do you think what's your
favorite parts of the Caribbean movie
tell us in the comments below